foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about life
specifically your money your
relationships your work and everything
that is connected and in between all of
those heavy categories I'm Ken Coleman
joined by my colleague Dr John deloney
with Ramsey personalities we host our
own shows as a part of the Ramsey
Network and this hour we are your host
we are here for you John what are we
going to talk to them about everything
relationships mental health was going on
in their lives what's going on in their
workplace their money whatever's going
on we'll we'll sit here with you and
we'll walk alongside you there you go
all right let's go to Noel who joins us
in the Big Apple New York City there you
go Noelle how can we help
hi
um pleasure to talk to you guys um I
just moved to New York City uh to take
my dream job and
um doing well uh the Sally's you know
decent for the city and I have no debt
but I was wondering I don't think I can
afford to buy something for you know a
very long time and I'm wondering if it's
okay to just increase retirement or
should I still put money aside to be
able to buy something eventually how
long is a long time
well
um I mean I don't know probably
10 years
well can you continue to save
aggressively over a 10-year period and
continue to pay the rent that you have
to pay and get there in 10 years if you
really lock down and get the down
payment there in 10 years can you do
that
some inheritance but I just want to know
if it's okay to to do more than 15
percent
um
you know if I think it's Outreach to buy
something
well
is is it okay it's certainly never wrong
when someone invests more but that's our
rule of thumb as Dave has prescribed the
baby steps and there's a reason for that
so if you think about baby step four so
if you're new to our program just kind
of reset real quick so you can get uh
caught up with where Noelle is asking
the question baby step one is we ask you
to put or we recommend you put a
thousand dollars in your savings account
just to handle any kind of rainy day uh
pop-up emergency then you take on all of
your debt and baby step two that's what
we call the debt snowball and you go
after your smallest debt first moving up
to the largest debt so you get momentum
and every time you pay off on the
smaller debts you roll that payment into
the next largest debt and that gets you
tremendous momentum baby step three is
saving three to six months of your
expenses so now we're really juicing the
emergency fund baby step four is to set
aside 15 of your income what you're
taking home into a matching 401k or a
Roth IRA so that's where we stand right
now all right baby step five is people
saving for uh their kids college now
well they have a a step that was kind of
developed later 3B where people uh go
after the three to six months of
expenses into uh saving for a house and
essentially that's where you would be
right is that you would be saving for
the house but it's going to take you
quite some time and I I wonder if you're
going to be in New York long term you
know you sound like a young man is that
true is that is it possible that you'll
be moving out of the city or you think
you're there long term well I'm young
but it's been my goal to get here and
I've I've been dreaming for 12 years to
get to the right job and situation to do
it and I do think I'm going to stay here
for this foreseeable future so there's
something underneath the purchasing
question besides dollars and cents what
is it
well
um
I guess since I'm here's why you're
saving for a retirement someday so you
have you believe that you're going to
accumulate X number of dollars down the
road and you're willing to invest to
make that happen you are not willing to
invest that it to make a home happen why
uh because
it seems like to get a substantial down
payment is it just gonna take me a good
amount of time to do that so you're just
going to work are you just gonna quit on
that
um no well so right now I'm putting so
my my salary is 90 000 I'm putting uh
1200 a month to various retirement
accounts and I'm putting 500 a month in
my savings account so as that slowly
builds up which that will take in uh
quite a long time to get a down payment
for a house actually or a condo up here
um so I'm wondering if that 500 a month
in savings should I just you know divert
that to my retirement account I don't
know I'm not certain so I'm I'm not
gonna make that mistake of of putting a
stake in the ground whether it's causal
or correlative but in the millionaire
study
the vast majority of millionaires had
paid for houses
right and they were able to over Time
Capture the most volatile and expensive
part of their life which is fluctuating
housing costs by taking that equation
off the table that's why we tell people
pay your mortgage off even if you have a
great interest rate because it just
takes that off the table there's no risk
in it you you you are completely
um on your own at that point and what
you're choosing to do if you think about
it you're choosing to be at the mercy of
a fluctuating Market over time which we
all I think it's just gonna be I think
it's gonna be fine but that you're
putting yourself in that on that roller
coaster and at the same time you're
choosing to remain forever in a Land of
increasing rents or increasing hey your
building just got sold and so we're
going to sell to somebody else who's
going to jack your rent up it may move
your rent down here you're you're
signing up for a life of chaos and what
I hear is resignation you're just
quitting it's gonna take a long time to
get this so I'm instead I'm just gonna
put all my money over here and
retirement and I'm just going to I'm
going to just bet on the Gap there
between whatever rent escalation I have
whatever money I think I can earn in the
market and I think long term that's a
that's not a good move
okay what do you think your uh what do
you think the next three to five years
looks like as it relates to opportunity
for your income to increase
significantly
well
I'll stick with my current company I
came in at kind of low level management
level and I I do see opportunities
um within the company so
uh my point is it it would have seemed
to me that you're going to be making 150
200 in the next three to five years you
got a shot at that is that is that too
much for me to assume
uh that that seems reasonable yeah okay
well so John this comes back to we we
recommend the baby steps for a reason
right your life moves with you as you go
down these baby steps are you do you
have any other debt besides uh if you
have any other debt
and you've got your three to six months
expenses yes
yeah I have about uh 20 000 as my
emergency fund maybe it should be a
little more but um what's the number you
need the down payment number
well probably so so I guess 20 of
I'm not looking for anything big so it's
probably gonna be like a four or five
hundred thousand dollars
can you get fifty thousand dollars in
the next 24 months
I had probably yeah I can almost
guarantee you could yeah put 10 down on
it put 15 down on it and get yourself a
condo and get into a place where you can
control the rent escalation yeah uh for
the next 20 30 years of your life man
yeah yeah I I and again I think we're
pausing are we pausing baby step four
here for him to just pile up that money
I would I would I think you're 3B and I
think that uh I would stop the 15
investment and just pile up the cash get
in uh like John said and now we begin to
pay that house off and you can start
reinvesting you're gonna get caught back
up you're not gonna lose ground if
you're staying in New York long term
that's the play I agree hey thank you
for the call Noel the best is yet to be
don't move more Ramsey show coming up
foreign
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Dr John
deloney the shower we are here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five taking the money questions
taking the life questions in the area of
relationships your mental health
emotional health how about your work you
got a toxic co-worker or co-workers or a
leader who's driving you nuts with
horrible glossary how do I get a bigger
shovel to make more money to get out of
debt we're going to take all of those
calls Triple eight eight two five five
two two five hey when our team gets
together at Ramsey Solutions we talk a
lot about our mission to change
America's toxic culture in the area of
money and mental health and work and
Beyond quite frankly it makes us a
little upset to see people get trapped
by debt or a dead-end job or by their
past
um for the folks who work here this is
not a job it's a mission to meet those
people where they are so that sounds
like something you could get excited
about you've got to check out all the
exciting roles that we're offering at
Ramsey Solutions right now there's never
been a better time to find a job doing
work you love we need developers ux
designers and writers to help us build
digital products to see what it's like
to do work that matters with us before
you apply follow us on Instagram and
Facebook by searching Ramsey careers
apply for your dream job at
ramseysolutions.com
slash careers that's ramseysolutions.com
careers triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to jump in
Clarissa is up next in Houston Texas
that's John deloney territorial
Clarissa how can we help
hi gentlemen thank you for taking my
call
um I am expecting my fourth child here
in a few months and um I want to upgrade
in car
um right now I drive a CRV which cannot
physically fit all the number of
children that we have of course uh
myself and my husband and I'd like to
get a a Model X Tesla and I'm trying to
see if it all makes sense now forgive me
I really don't know much about Tesla's
our colleague George I would like that
car too yeah yeah he George has got one
Rachel's got one they love the old Tesla
but will that fit the whole family
uh so myself my husband and our four
children yes with a six seat
configuration it was at six seats but
a few uh car seats and the luggage for
when y'all travel
so for the luggage we'll have to get
creative I found like a mobile
trailer that we can attach that's super
cute that can go with a hole it's super
cuter
[Laughter]
hey you are how much is this car
oh clear so I'm trying to be nice yeah
how much is the car
so the car I'm looking at a used model
and so the range is about 86 to 90 000.
can you afford said Carr meaning pay
cash
yes I can I just don't know if I should
no you shouldn't well you can hear your
voice please break down that total voice
change doc I feel like there's something
there yes this is some this is somebody
who absolutely knows the answer to the
question here's what you're wrestling
with who you still want to see yourself
as and reality oh
reality is you're an awesome cool mom of
four an awesome cool wife and you all
are doing life
in in your fantasy you're still Super
Rad and cool and you're still going out
to Fitzgerald's out there and why I
guess they tore it down you're still
going out and doing cool stuff and
you're driving a Tesla to get there
is that fair
I am a cool mom yeah
is what I'm saying what's your what's
your annual take-home household
um annual take-home is about 330 000.
okay do you have any debt at all
um we owe 424 on the house okay so no
debt budget house
uh what's the other car worth the the
car maybe your hubs will drive
uh well my husband actually has a Tesla
of course he does a model three he's
still a cool guy he's so cool and I'm
over here in the CRP okay
yeah boring mom while husband's off
being cool plugging his car in so you
got the cash that we would get rid of it
would be worth twenty thousand all right
so you've got you've got the cash right
now you can go buy it right now
right is that the fully funded emergency
fund I'm trying to find a hole here John
this isn't a math problem
does it make sense yeah does it make
sense well I think it comes down to I
mean based on the formulas yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying this isn't a math
problem you can afford the car and so
there's our principals get it then go
ahead and do it in terms of
is are you going to be happy with this
purchase long term for your family and
are you buying a 90 000 depreciating
asset for four kids who are of a certain
size now and in five years they're going
to be double that size
all crammed into they're gonna destroy
this car you know this right they will
be walking no there's going to be
Cheerios smashed in there gummy
it's gonna be a car I I wouldn't do it
on that alone I didn't think about that
Ken I would buy a car to get me through
the next five years and tell my kids to
get the sweet toast right you can go to
the bathroom on their own let's let's
start there right and then get a Tesla
Maybe by then they'll have Tesla
minivans I mean Clarissa the way you
your intonation changed you were like I
know you know like what but what I want
to know why you called us to get our
opinion two dudes that you barely know
what are you doubting what feels weird
about it tell us
um well I I know math and I know that
there's a reason why I've driven this
BRB for this number of years I know that
cars are depreciating asset it doesn't
make sense but I also just like I'm
spending about two times longer in my
car every day than I used to I have a
newer job so I'm like well if I'm in
here like an hour and a half a day
instead of you know 45 minutes a day I
want to enjoy that yeah well have you
looked at that makes sense but let me
ask you this have you because see I'm
now by the way I want to be very clear
because John did a good job of saying
from a math standpoint if you're calling
us does this make sense financially you
guys can do this so it's a non-factor
it's not a bad decision but it I'm
actually done in our playing off of your
voice yeah and what you're feeling and I
heard now you told us and thank you so
here's the deal what would make you feel
really awesome for 45
000.
are you a less cool Mom are you not who
you want to be in a 50 000 Sienna hybrid
that it can fit everybody and all the
luggage and gets about 45 miles a gallon
50 miles a gallon
I don't know what that is it's a it's a
Toyota minivan Toyota minivan yeah
that's that sounds pretty
cool that's what's going on but what
what sounds terrible the image of
yourself in that minivan
um just the idea of driving a minivan
okay but wait a second but wait a second
I'm going to keep pushing because John
gave you one option I'm gonna give you
another option what about a really
awesome SUV again that you can maybe get
for 45. maybe it's got a little bit
higher miles maybe it's got fifty
thousand sixty thousand miles but that's
nothing that's Tahoe Suburban yeah
what's wrong with one of those
I don't like the way that they maneuver
and so which one of you is from Houston
because driving around in one of those
yeah for an hour and a half in Houston
traffic is terrible switching Lane tiny
parking it is but also there's rocks
flying everywhere because they tear down
a new highway every other weekend for no
reason right so I mean it it's it goes
back to the 90 000 appreciating asset
that's going to be destroyed on the
outside and on the inside I think of all
the things I've heard as we're thinking
this out loud it's what Ken said about
what these four kids crammed into this
beautiful wonderful car and if you call
me and said hey I got one kid or I'm
single we'd tell you dude buy it right
now yeah I'd be jealous of you because
I'd love to have that car
um but this is just us telling our
friend or our sister dude kids destroy
him nuclear scientists have found that
goldfish Will Survive those little
treats those little cheesy treats will
survive a nuclear blast yes and you know
gonna live in those crevices that even
your vacuum cleaner can't get to you
know the long neck foreign
the world's greatest adhesive melted
gummy bear yeah that sits under or
melted organic fruit snack that's that's
all you can eat in a Tesla by the way
and no matter what they tell you about
that awesome chemical you can buy at
your favorite store big box stores your
kid's gonna drop a smoothie and it's
gonna stain that carpet inside of six
months and guess what it ain't coming
out nope nope hey you buy what you want
to buy yeah you can do it I'm more
worried about you not liking yourself in
a vehicle that tells me you got deeper
things going on there that's where I
would start but if you do buy it would
you please email the Ramsay show the
picture of you and your cute little
Tesla wagon with all the way to the
beach crammed in there that's right I
want to see that we're going to the
beach everybody in our live space for
one towel that's it all right folks
don't move more of that kind of Genius
wisdom coming up this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Cohen joined by Dr John deloney and we
are here for you taking your phone calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five that is triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's free call
uh folks give us a shot it's you know it
is a free call and we care deeply about
you and you may be just one phone call
away from breakthrough and if you've got
something that's a little bit sensitive
uh know that we're going to protect you
and take good care of you we'll change
your name your location everything if
you feel like you need to talk to
somebody today we are here for you so
give us a shout Bradley's going to start
us off this segment in Charlotte North
Carolina Bradley how can we help
we are having a blast what's up
so I'm gonna give you a little
background uh I'm 24 my wife's 23 uh
we've been married uh since the middle
of last year we just had a new son he's
about three months old
and we currently have been living in our
house right now we have a mortgage on it
uh for a little over three years
and we now because of our son we're
wanting to move closer to family and uh
you know different uh school district
and stuff like that and we want to do
that within you know like three to five
years give or take
and so I didn't know if it'd be best to
keep throwing you know
additional money into the mortgage try
to pay it down as quickly as I can or if
I need to draw back on that and instead
use that money towards the you know the
anything past my emergency fund to put
down towards the next house
that kind of stuff
um I
three to five years let me say it this
way you're gonna get your money back out
of your house more than likely so right
I personally what I do is I dump all
that money into my house
um if I was gonna move I'd dump all that
money into my house so let me get it
back when I sell it it feels it's like a
pseudo like a warm blankie to feel like
I've got a checking account over here
with some other money in it but it's
it's going to end up in the same pot
um three to five years you're right on
the cusp on one end and you're right at
the beginning of of a custom on the
other end right so if you told me hey in
three years we're out of here two and a
half years we put our house on the
market we're gonna start looking to get
out of here I'd probably tell you to
Sock some money away and try to sell
that house if you tell me to be there
five years that's a I try to pay that
house off as fast as I could right so
you're right Square in the middle why'd
you pick that time range like what is
Magic maybe three to five years
well uh the actual well the limit would
be you know five because that's when our
sum would be roughly starting school so
that's why I kind of mentioned like the
school district thing so let me let me
rephrase it why not move right now why
not move this summer
uh mainly well I mean we're just kind of
saving up money right now because uh you
know obviously our minds you know the
more money you put down the better we
want to finance as least as possible so
we're kind of building you know that
Nest Egg up at the moment okay yeah but
here's the deal and John is absolutely
right Bradley and the reason he's right
and uh how old did you say you were
24 24. take it from dudes who are twice
as old as you and I it's certainly me I
don't know about John I shouldn't you're
close close twice
um
a lot can change in one year
your life can look unrecognizable in
three to five and I like John's advice
because investing in the current house
there's no negative you keep paying that
house down
um he's right you're going to get that
money back most likely and you've got
yourself so much more net worth so much
more Equity you've got options life can
change and I love the plan and I'm not
in any way trying to poo poo or scare
you uh I just want you to understand
life can change and I think John's
advice is right I would pile everything
into the house that effectively becomes
your down payment that equity and again
I haven't thought about that but
um Roger's been through it you and I
have been married a long time well let
me back it out three years ago I was in
my dream job at one of the top
universities in the country and then two
years before that I was in another state
in a really great job doing right so man
to forecast five years in my life and I
ran into somebody and now I have I'm a
YouTuber as my kid as my son says so man
you have no idea what happens in five
years whether a boss comes and Taps you
on the shoulder you get fired your wife
gets promote who knows right so it's
important to plan it's important to have
dreams and it's important to be very
specific about those dreams and it's
also important to live with principles
in the present right here's where I'm
going to be every single day in route to
wherever where he is we're going yeah I
love the advice John uh Bradley I
couldn't couldn't agree more just piling
into the current house and then when we
get there when there shows up uh you're
gonna be in great shape thank you for
the call Paul is up next in Cincinnati
Ohio Paul how can we help
hey Ken and John I'm actually really
glad that you two are on hosting the
show today because uh perfect
combination for this question hey nobody
ever says that Paul thanks man yeah can
we record that guys in the booth it'd be
great if you could send that home to our
wives and kids that'd be wonderful
what's up so um so my best friend
suffers from debilitating anxiety and it
has had him out of work for about the
past year and a half and I'm wondering
what I can do or what I can encourage
him with that might help him move back
into the work field since he's been
making some progress with his anxiety
that's awesome so I would reframe that
question that statement a little bit and
say something about his life
has set off his body's alarm systems
and the noise is real loud so putting
anxiety to the side what is it about his
ecosystem or his environment that has
begun has suffocating him is it his
marriage did he lose somebody is he have
childhood trauma he's dealing with like
what what is it
so I'd say it's mostly from his
childhood trauma okay okay and so he's
found himself in an adult world and his
body is struggling to live in a world
that we've all created for ourselves
that none of us can live in right
yeah okay uh hey by the way he's lucky
to have you
it's pretty awesome
um here's what I will tell you two two
important things number one you can't
fix him and the more you try to help him
by fixing him as though he's a puzzle
and you've got the missing pieces the
more he becomes a project and not
somebody you love he becomes an engine
to fix not a friend
and as somebody who's been where he is
just debilitated by anxiety
the greatest thing my friends and
there's a couple of them John a friend
named Todd if her name Randall for name
like guys who leaned into my life they
were very clear about you're with us
we're inviting you over even though you
come over and you're annoying or you
want to talk about all the end of the
monetary policies coming like all these
crazy anxious things I had all the time
they always invited me over and a couple
of my buddies called me on my nonsense
here's something important for you to
understand that debilitating anxiety is
a context it's his body getting his
attention and he sounds like he's on on
the path to Healing
it is an excuse to show up in your life
so I had a friend who said who one time
came I had you know you may have heard
my story I I thought I was seeing cracks
every time my house was falling apart he
came over to my house he looked at it
his dad was an architect he's been on
group on construction sites and he
walked around and he took me out we're
outside I was like look at this look at
this and he took a breath as a good
Texan would do and he exhaled and he
said your house is strong your house is
fine this conversation's over and I
don't ever want to hear you mention this
again
and here's what he gave me in that
moment that was the first time someone
had said stop with this nonsense
and it allowed me to walk away and think
huh maybe the issue lies with inside of
me not projecting out all of it but see
what I'm saying but he wasn't ugly he
showed up he came into the he I I
invited him into my life and he showed
up and he loved me enough to hold me
accountable are you taking care of
yourself right you see what I'm saying
so you can't fix him you can love him
and that's real frustrating for a good
friend like you right well you can also
do a couple other things Paul
um John's absolutely right you gotta
love him but you know what you can do
you can encourage him be very very
positive he just a voice of positivity
and consistent positivity that's the
encouragement you can also connect him
to people that you know to say hey let
me tell you about my buddy he's had a
rough life and uh but I know he's a good
dude and and and and I want you to give
him a shot you can connect him to
Opportunities through your relationships
and then the third thing is you can
endorse him endorse him to as many
people as possible that's what a friend
can do your question was how can I help
my friend find a job well you can look a
little bit for him at the end of the day
you got to connect him because I think
he feels wounded John oh yeah I think
he's a little bit maybe shameful
embarrassed whatever and finding a job
explaining him to a situation is one of
the best things a friend can do that's
exactly right and and just showing up be
in there so connecting man open up your
Rolodex put yourself out there for him
but in doing so tell him hey dude this
guy stop yeah because I believe in you
my name on it you're gonna show up you
got to show up and you got to deliver
and I believe you can show up that's it
I think that's the right thing to do and
then as John said Paul you you just got
to be his friend and loving you can't do
it all for him but great call thanks for
calling this is the ranch
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John Delaney joins me this
hour we are here for you America the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
um I gotta tell I gotta tell the folks
this really quick I just showed John an
old video uh uh on YouTube of the guy in
Australia who is trying to rescue his
dog from the kangaroo and they square up
out in the the bush of Australia and the
right lead the guy if you haven't seen
this video James is going his kid what
is Ken doing I just need to share the
goodness it made your day did it not it
was fantastic guy punches the kangaroo
and rescues his dog from the from the
from the grasp of the kangaroo and this
kangaroo just spreads up and just think
and it looks like two high school kids
yeah but then that guy crosses his feet
and boom yeah catches him punches and
the kangaroo is obviously has no idea
what has just happened but he takes it
right to the jaw it was beautiful and
they both kind of look at each other and
then yeah we should separate yeah so
there's a little bonus content if you've
never seen it John had never seen the
video and it made his day so go check it
out guy punches Kangaroo on YouTube
change your life set good see you come
you don't oh there it is right there it
is they're putting it up on the screen
for YouTube look at that just a right
lead and they just stare at each other
and the kangaroo is like what is watch
this look he squares up this guy's boom
right there pow and then he just and
then the guy turns us back to the
kangaroo and goes get in the truck dogs
yep walks away if I could ever meet this
guy and interview him it would be a it
would be a delight James gonna set that
up yeah there it is can you set that up
all right folks uh see you never know
what we might talk about here on the
Ramsay show let's go to Chris uh in
Sacramento California Chris how can we
help
hi how's it going thank you um
I have a car buying question like run by
you guys okay
so I'm currently considering trading
into a newer vehicle a bigger vehicle a
SUV and I just want to know if it would
be a smart move I'm currently driving a
2020 Kia Forte
and I was looking to trade into a 2022
Kia Sorento all right run the numbers
for us well what do you do you owe on
the first car
no sir I do not owe anything I own it um
it's a praise approximately between
16 000 to 18 000 at the most all right
what's the other car
yeah car I'm proudly realistically
looking at 40 uh forty five thousand
When Calls haven't done and I'm assuming
you've got cash to be able to do this
well I don't know how new you are to the
show that I don't want to presume right
but we we are never going to say that it
is a good move or smart move however you
just put it
to go into debt for a car please don't
borrow money on a depreciating asset
Chris please please please please it's
not good you're worth more than that
do you understand where we're coming
from on that we're not going to debate
you but we want you to understand why we
say that do you understand why we're
saying that and what John means by
you're gonna you're gonna go into debt
on a asset that is depreciating every
day
okay do you understand what we're saying
yes sir I do is there anything wrong
with your uh Kia or is that what you
said it was
yes sir yes 2020 Kia Sorrento is there
anything wrong with it yeah it's
perfectly good car and it's paid for
correct
yes sir no there's nothing wrong with it
how much do you make what's your annual
income
gross or not sir
take home take home excuse me take home
before you agree possibly forty three
thousand through okay and that's that's
the other part is just as a general rule
of thumb again this is us talking to
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people over 30 years right is when you
get your ratios out of whack you find
yourself in a hole whether you meant to
or not and you're thinking about buying
a car on credit that's about as much as
you bring home on an annual basis
just thinking about that I bought a
depreciating asset for all the money I'm
going to make in the calendar year
so our rule of thumb is everything in
your home with engines and wheels should
not
um
should not exceed half of your annual
income and I personally actually think
that's high but that's where we've
landed so you're looking in the twenty
thousand dollar twenty one thousand
dollar range and it sounds like you've
got that perfectly right now are you can
you be content with Where You Are
time to contend yes sir how come you
want to trade up
because you know sir the the vehicle
ahead is kind of like a a bad Relic a
little bad
um a bad emergency I had a couple years
ago and uh tell me about that
so unfortunately two years ago I was the
victim of one of those
Social Security FBI gift card scams
um you know these these guys scared me
and so long story short they scanned me
out of
four or five hundred dollars
um and
I had other plans to do with that money
so the only way I had I
came up with to get it back was to trade
down into the from the vehicle I was
driving at the time so I that's what I
did so it just reminds you every day of
that season huh
yes sir yeah another thing is that
there's a little kind of tiny for kind
of amount of driving I do it's kind of
tiny well then hey I get that yeah
absolutely I would just be patient like
let's do this but let's be patient and
let's be smart let's not let's not buy a
car that is is you know is worth as much
as John said you're gonna make in a year
so I would be patient save up the money
um and and be smart about this don't
don't be in a rush to make this change I
understand why you want to make the
change and I think you should make the
change yeah well we just want you to do
it cash no debt do you owe any other
money
oh
about 18
000 sorry 19 000 on a personal loan okay
I've got a I've got a even crazier idea
for you
what if you sold this
uh he says 18 000 trade-in which means
you get 20 for it on the private Market
what if you sold it for 20
bought a ten thousand dollar Camry
and then took that other ten thousand
bucks and threw it towards your debt now
you're out of this car that reminds you
of a dark moment you're in a car that's
gonna it's not sexy it's not cool but
it's gonna run till the apocalypse is
over and you can make some Headway on
cleaning your debt up so that you can
for the first time in your adult life
breathe
I actually hadn't considered that option
yes how does that feel well I think it
sounds great but I'm biased he's my
friend and it actually makes sense of
this weekend you could only owe 8 000
bucks how does that feel Chris how does
that feel as you were processing that
you know like
um
like you said the
it was it would remove the kind of
reminder like I kind of would like to do
with kind of the the the uh the
circumstances
and cut your debt in half
yeah it feels pretty good that's the
answer I'm looking for because I know
that felt good as you started to process
that right and then you've got 8 000
bucks left that you owe somebody I want
you to spend the next calendar year
putting every penny you got to pay that
stuff off and then by the end of 2023 I
want you to be completely 100 a free man
yes and I'm going to challenge you a
little bit more six months go work an
extra job
right go get a part-time job making 20
bucks an hour six months or less you're
completely debt free with John's plan
then we started saving towards the nicer
car and and moving on with your life
what do you do for a living
I'm in the Army sir I'm an army officer
sir no that's why you keep calling me
sir I was wondering
um uh how much longer do you got
currently only I only have three more
years active duty that I have to do all
I'm looking to do six more years great
um
man I'd love to see you Hammer this out
and figure it out
and be completely 100 debt free even if
that meant you got to move back on base
for a season and get control of the
number of veterans that we talk to are
active duty folks that we talk to who
have been either scammed or have found
them hey at least you got a Kia man you
didn't get yourself the uh Jeep with the
jacked up all the stuff on it right but
man I would love to see you look up in
24 36 months and you owe nobody anything
and you're driving the car that you want
that you paid for in cash because you're
a free man I would love love love that
man you deserve that life
[Music]
thanks for your service Chris and you've
got this hopefully you'll take our
advice I think the best is yet to be for
you thank you so much for your call I
want to thank John deloney and James the
crew behind the class thank you guys for
keeping us afloat but mostly thank you
America this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsey show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where America hangs out
to talk about life specifically your
money life your relationship mental and
emotional health part of your life your
work life we're going to talk about it
all I'm Ken Coleman joined by Dr John
baloney and we are here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five it is a toll-free number
you may just be one phone call away from
breakthrough we'd love to try to help
give you a practical plan for hope for a
better future triple eight eight two
five five two two five that is the
number two jump in Betty is going to
start us office hour in Reno Nevada
Betty how can we help
hi um so my question was um
should I go back to work hold strong or
maybe move some money from stocks
currently I'm a stay-at-home mom I used
to teach seventh grade and
um as we've been on a single income
since April because I was on put on bed
rest after my second pregnancy
I am going to school part-time to get a
master's so I do plan to go back to work
to teach but in Our Hope was in two
years once that program is over them and
but right now
our savings are depleting we're down to
17
000. our take home with my husband
single income is around 3 500 but our
expenses are coming out to like 4 500.
are those
I'm gonna ask this since gonna sound
dismissive so understand I'm asking this
as though we're just hanging out okay
this isn't me being ugly
um are your expenses truly forty five
hundred dollars or did you all adjust
your income when you chose to stay home
you just didn't adjust your lifestyle
budgeting budgeting budgeting our
mortgage is about to about two thousand
okay so you're you guys are busting it
to you're you've cut everywhere you can
cut
yeah okay do you have any debts pretty
much no we actually after my first son
was born in 2020 we have all others that
um uh we paid it off and so we're just
working on our mortgage now okay well
here's the thing
um we don't want you using that
emergency fund the way you're using that
right now that emergency fund is for an
emergency it is not a floating fund
um yeah and because of the fact that
you're eventually headed back to the
classroom
um I'm having a dinner table
conversation tonight I mean this is this
is a family meeting and we've got to get
some more income so the way I see it uh
there are two ways to get more income
Betty one you go back to full time or
part-time work
um or your husband takes on an extra job
right now so this comes down to two
things it is a financial decision but
it's also you're at home for this season
anyway uh for a reason correct yeah yes
exactly so we have another
a possibility too I'm wondering if if we
should do this my husband gets um
from work and so he we have like 90 000
restricted stocks vested
um so I don't know if we should take
some of that out
I I would not for this because this is
see again it sounds attractive but
you're coming up with a bandage with the
stock thing
yeah it would it would it would uh give
you a little bit more time it would
replenish your savings but you're going
to pay taxes on that uh if you're going
to do anything with the stock you know
what I would do I would invest that
wisely and let that be working for you
that's what I would be doing with the
stock I I would not be using it to live
off of
um I think it comes down to who's going
to take care of the kiddos if you go
back to work have you walked through
that
and see that's part of the reason why
I'm staying because the only daycare
close by wasn't really great at all
okay so for the moment let's go okay
it's not ideal for you to go back to
work right now when you were planning to
go back after the masters with the kids
be I mean you still have to have a
daycare situation right well at that
point we were thinking of relocating to
California where we have family that's
where I was getting I might I might fast
forward that absolutely yes I would go
ahead and move near family now
and allow for uh the family to come
around you
so that you can get back into work and
get back teaching and do the the Masters
on the side anyway I would just fast
forward that whole plan yeah absolutely
Betty you are grappling with what
millions and millions and millions of
Americans are grappling with is the cost
of doing life has just gotten so
expensive and jobs like you were doing
like being a teacher I met with some
some uh
uh K-12 administrators yesterday and the
starting salaries are very similar to
what they were when I was a high school
teacher and that was a long time ago so
the cost of doing life has gotten more
expensive and the cost for some of these
jobs hasn't you found yourself there and
what you found is
um it's an uncomfortable nobody likes to
talk about it and and it's like Hush
Hush but you've landed in a mathematical
reality to continue to live here doing
the work that we love to do and having
kids is no longer feasible so we either
have to change jobs we have to change
locations we have to make concessions
Ken and I have both driven all over the
city to drop our kids off at various
places because there wasn't one by our
house that may be part of it and so that
means your day looks a little bit
different that means husband's got to
cook dinner because you're going to be
whatever it is you're having to own
reality acknowledge it and you can't
just say well this is just where we live
you can't if you've got a thousand
dollar gap between income and bills
right so man I'm with Ken I would
accelerate that move to California I
would be super clear about the financial
aspects of this and I might even pause
that master's degree because that's
costing you money that quite frankly
y'all don't have right now and that
master's degree is always going to be
there and you might find a school
district that'll pay for it for you
that's exactly right uh you're a teacher
you've been a teacher
um I like this move I really do I I
wouldn't put any other option up there I
I hope you all go this route
um and you know the child care thing
John it just it's a nightmare it it is
so prohibitive yeah it's amazing to to
working women oh yeah I I was reading
something recently we knew this shortly
after the pandemic really hit about six
months into 2020 we saw data come out
where a ton of professional women had to
go home and that was because everything
was shut down and they were the you know
they're the moms and they went home and
it set back professional women
tremendously yes and at the same time
child care costs have escalated and so
it's keeping women back yes I can't
afford to go work can't go back right it
is cost prohibitive to go to work right
yeah
um and that makes me angry it's an
absolute mess yeah and we as a society
and I don't I'm gonna just this is
dangerous to to expose a problem without
a solution right
um but I can say with confidence we the
people have the brain power on both
sides of the political aisle we got to
figure this out take care of Moms God's
sakes we got to figure out child care in
this situation so that when people come
I mean we get there there's got to be a
way and I know there's some bright
people a whole lot smarter than me they
can figure it out especially when you
look at the down extreme cost of well
yeah
how much we spend on the back end of
some of these challenges man that could
be solved if we take care of mothers and
we take care of kids good grief yeah so
anyway there you go daddy make the move
the good news is you have a support
Cisco family for you and your hubs and
uh I'm very excited for you guys boy
life is gonna be a lot easier put that
house for sale up and make a move thank
you so much for the call for the rest of
you don't move we got more Ramsay show
right around the corner
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back America you have joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five last week we were in Phoenix
John for two amazing crowds that sold
out events on the Building Wealth tour
and uh if you've been thinking about
joining our fall Building Wealth tour
you better move quickly the events in
Sacramento and San Antonio are
completely sold out but we still have a
few seats left for our Building Wealth
Minneapolis event on November 10th I
think I might wear a turtleneck to that
one I might try to see if I could uh see
if I can maybe Rock the turtleneck what
do you think I will not wear a
turtleneck I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
we'll see don't tell Dave we'll just
surprise him uh if you want tickets you
need to buy them now prices for
Minneapolis go up this Friday so to get
the early bird discount before it's too
late you better move me Dr John deloney
Rachel Cruz George Campbell and Dave
Ramsey all are there we'll talk about
Building Wealth in this current economy
and show you how you can get on a path
to building the wealth that you desire
uh so again recap of the dates uh
everything is sold out except
Minneapolis November the 10th tickets
start at 25 or you can get a four pack
starting at sixty dollars so tickets
start at 25 a four pack of tickets
starting at sixty dollars go to
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats now every time I read that
and I hear four pack I immediately think
of Chick-fil-A
that uh the four pack yeah but we're
talking about tickets not chicken
fingers I was thinking of craft beer but
I get what you're going with hey and by
the way on these Building Wealth tours
um don't forget Ken and I have been oh
yeah going to spend an hour before
um before Dave's uh talk basically just
doing our shows live
um the John Delaney show and the king
Coleman show and taking questions and
man there's been some really magic
moments it's been pretty neat
um listening to people's what they're
struggling with and trying to help them
find the next right step yeah a lot of
stress out there in our home lives and
our work lives and oddly enough
we can look to one side of those for
where a lot of the stress is coming from
a lot of stress at work sometimes it's
because of stuff going on at home and
vice versa so we team up on that that's
a lot of fun it's a pre-show you can uh
you can get your tickets to that as well
so go check that out uh all right let's
get back to the phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Kristen in Alberta Canada Kristen
how can we help
Hi how are you we're having a blast
what's going on
okay so I wanted to go to school next
year like in a year's time I just wanted
to know I have a little bit of debt I'm
planning to pay that off but um Is it
wise to to mortgage while I'm going to
school
where are you going to school
in Saskatoon Saskatchewan what are you
going to study
um
so ultimately I wanted to get into law
but I have to do a couple years some
Social Work degree okay in hopes of
getting into law school so you're going
to get us Social Work graduate degree
and then head towards or is that a
bachelor's degree
it's a bachelor so I'm I need two years
of something in order to even apply for
law school okay
work right so law schools at a minimum
three years out is that right and then
law school I'm assuming in in Canada
it's the same as it is in the states
that's a three-year course
yeah okay
um
I I I wouldn't
I wouldn't either no no I wouldn't I
would go rent because who knows what
after you finish your social work degree
what the job market looks like what the
law school entrance rate looks like what
all that you may be in in this area for
18 months and then all of a sudden you
need to get out yeah
I just think first of all it's so that
it's it's not that it's a bad idea I
just don't think it's the best idea and
we want to always try to give you the
best idea and I think what we're saying
is it gives you options you know once
you purchase a home a lot of things
change you feel like you're rooted there
and and you're getting after this you've
got a clear professional Direction you
want to go I would not do it I would
wait and especially since you don't know
if you've even got into law school yet
you haven't gotten to lost your period
you haven't gotten to law school there
you may end up in law school somewhere
in the states who knows where you're
gonna end up
what's the housing market like in Canada
um it's it's up and down I guess I was
looking at like town homes and and um
uh condos even and what's that purchase
price what's the purchase price
I can find one for 150 to 200 a decent
decent one yeah but those homes and
condos those townhomes and condos are
going to be there by the dozens
I'd sit tight
I would I'd get my degree and then
figure out what I'm going to be doing
which way were you leaning when you
called us
oh you were about to buy weren't you
100 gonna buy
cold why
I thought I'd be talked out of it
otherwise so that to see that makes me
wonder if if if you had a a good size of
Doubt there like you were like all right
I want this there's no question I want
it but should I do it and that's the
nature of your call I just would hold
tight I I it's just going to give you
more options here's it here's so
Christian I don't know if you know my
background but I spent five years as an
administrator in a law school so I've
worked at law schools and I love them
I'm glad you're going to do that the
world needs good legal Minds out there
serving the people
um the number of students who would come
in and then they would spend one year
somewhere else doing an externship they
would study abroad they would end up
working at this firm over the summer and
then have to come back during the year
it's a lot more mobile than you think it
is
and by buying a house you're tying
yourself down unnecessarily just doesn't
it it doesn't make sense um I would
solve for freedom in the next four or
five years
thank you for the call Kristen we're
excited about what you're going to be
doing let's go to San Diego California
now where Mark is on the line Mark how
can we help
hey how you doing we're having a blast
what's up
hey so yeah I'm um I've been dating this
girl for about nine months and we kind
of started talking about finances and
money
and she has about three hundred thousand
dollars in debt
um she had a PhD in um Pharmacy
so she's a pharmacy major making
around I think you're on a hundred
thousand dollars a year
and you know that was kind of a shock to
me because I
um I have no debt I have good credit
score I have an emergency fund I have
enough money to actually purchase a home
right now if I want to I have a thriving
business
and when we talked about it I kind of
said okay well you know if in the future
you know because we're not going to
share expenses or finances until we're
married
I would be happy to support the
household when we're married while
you're having your income mostly go to
the debt so we can kind of work on it
together
and that seemed like a good plan and
then
a couple weeks later she kind of brought
up you know the understanding of like oh
you know I have
um
a brother that's uh special needs that
you know might need financial assistance
in the future you know her parents are
taking care of him right now
so I'm trying to figure out okay what
would my responsibility be human she
kind of said you know there might even
be a team so we might need to take care
of my mom hypothetically but probably
not in the future financially so I'm
getting concerned because I feel like
the expectations are quickly
kind of increasing on me
to be able to
provide and
I don't know and I'm like
it's causing anxiety for me in a
relationship basically no question when
you marry somebody you marry their
family too
yeah right
and so I don't think it's out of Bounds
at all to take care of an aging parent I
don't think it's out of Bounds at all to
have a plan to take care of a special
needs brother and sister I think that's
beautiful
what you have to ask yourself is
is knowing that loving her comes with
also
taking helping support family
is that a life you want to buy into
that's the choice here don't don't over
complicate it
okay in fact it's I think it's beautiful
that she is that articulate up front
really I I read that a little
differently okay did you read it
differently than that Mark did it feel
presumptuous out of nowhere or did you
feel like it was an extension like John
saying I could be reading it wrong
um I don't know I mean okay hang on
we're gonna we're gonna dig in I want to
dig into this one yeah yeah hang on the
line Mark we're gonna go to a break here
I'm gonna put you on hold and we get
back uh I could be wrong there's some
onions here no no I might be I I just
wonder if he doesn't feel like whoa that
was a little fast when you came at me
with Mom and the brother
I don't know I actually want you to
spend more I want to watch you uh dig
into this one I'm gonna Dig Two
I agree with what you said let's do it
no let's do it I don't know this one
feels weird to me hang on folks this is
what we do here on the Ramsey show we
dig we dig deep it's gonna be great Mark
hold on this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Kidd Coleman joined by Dr John
deloney and as we were going into our
last break we had Mark with us on the
line in San Diego and so Mark uh just
going to reset this for you if you're
just joining us has been in a dating
relationship about nine months and Mark
is debt free
and makes a very good salary and his
girlfriend has a lot of debt uh through
a I believe a doctorate in in
Pharmaceuticals so he's going to be
making very good money and uh as they
begin to talk about the future potential
future of their relationship they begin
to talk about money
and uh in
subsequent conversations after the
initial Money Talks uh the girlfriend
brings up that uh she has a brother who
struggles with some uh health issues and
disabilities and so maybe they would
have to help with his finances and then
uh potentially her mom and so Mark was
like all right I mean I kind of like uh
well what do I do here and John I want
you to repeat your thought there and
that led us to what is he feeling but
you you said as we were going to break
what did you say ultimately
um it's not out of bounds for someone to
say hey I've got a brother with special
needs that I anticipate having to take
care of down the road right and by the
way I am hoping that
um or might be that one day one of my
parents is gonna have to come live with
us if the other one were to pass away
and so I want to have space in our
relationship for that because it's
probably going to happen
um I don't think that's out of Bounds at
all in fact I was saying I like the fact
that she's this clear this soon
but something is a little bit off and I
just felt like Mark maybe you called us
because it and not to say that she's got
any uh untoward uh ideas but it felt
like maybe it caught you off guard and
and maybe you're like oh how should I
react to this how how are you feeling
about this
yeah I guess it's difficult for me is
it's kind of like um like I'm a planner
like I like to understand the
expectation that's put on me I'm
good at like solving problems and many
guys minimizing risk and to me it's
almost like okay so like if maybe I
should already be starting to fund you
know for the brother or for I don't know
her extended family or something all
right so let me let me push a little bit
more do you feel uncomfortable did you
feel uncomfortable when she brought up
her mom and helping out with her Mom's
finances I understand the brother who
cannot help himself am I am I reading
that correctly
yes but what about the mom did that make
you feel like why should I have I'm just
curious and maybe you didn't but I just
want to know
the yeah so if I mean truthful the
reason why is because
she has kind of told me how her mom is
kind of passive aggressive and can be
very controlling and my interaction with
her haven't been bad but it hasn't been
great so I think obviously if I had more
love and connection with her over time
then of course I'd want to help out a
loved one all right so now I'm glad I
dug John now now how do you react to
that so here's what it sounds like it
sounds like you have a picture in your
mind of what you getting married is
going to look like
yeah and you can prep for that by
getting all the funds in the right place
getting all the genes in the right
drawer and getting all the cars in the
right place in the garage
and what I would tell you is this
all relationships a hundred percent of
them whether you've been married one
week or 50 years all relationships are a
risk
yeah you open yourself up to somebody
could hurt you and the beauty of a
marriage is somebody says I'm going to
open up myself to you fully
and you are going to spend the rest of
your life loving me and I'm going to do
the same back to you and the scary part
about it is it only works if both people
jump with both feet and we get a lot of
flack here for telling people to share
bank accounts to talk every week about
their schedules and things like that no
I got to be me bro dude it's not gonna
work you both got to be all in and that
means you have to say I'm gonna plan I'm
going to dream but we're going to plan
and dream together and that is a skill
set that you don't have and that's okay
very few people have that going into
marriage
um yeah you just have to decide you want
to learn that but like okay I'm I'm
gonna I I don't feel right about this so
John I want you to keep going keep going
I think you're okay planning for the
brother I don't think you're okay I
don't think you've bought into the fact
that you even need to support mom and I
quite frankly sitting here go I'm not
sure I'm signing up for that
am I onto something yeah so here's the
deal are you ready to marry this woman
are you just talking about it
um I think I'm ready
I think I'm ready I mean I I love her
and I want to marry her and I
I don't yeah I don't know yeah but I
know you don't because let me put it
this way
if
she had not brought up taking care of
Mom
how would you have answered that
question
um come on man I think it would have
answered a little bit differently
I think I need to be able to have the
conversation just with her in a more I
think so too uh John I'm gonna throw it
back to you on because I've appreciated
everything you said yeah but I slight I
go I don't think he has to to put
himself out there no he doesn't have to
hey here's the thing I think he's got to
tell her okay so here's what I think
Mark I think John I'm gonna pass it back
to you I would like to see him sit down
with her and go okay here's what I'm
feeling about this yes I'd like to know
your Mom's finances I want to know the
whole picture if we're talking about
you're expecting me to maybe help I want
to know the whole enchilada what's
Mama's Finance situation and see what we
what the risk would be and how old is
Mama right and can mama get her acting
gear and and I'll support mom if she
does this this and this and she needs a
place to stay yes but as far as letting
her run up debt and be irresponsible
with money when I don't agree with that
I'm not buying into that I guess Mark
that's what I'm feeling underneath the
surface am I right
I completely agree isn't it kind of like
and just in general if I'm lending money
to family members or that I'm crossing
that threshold that is kind of my
responsibility to have an understanding
of like yeah
so hey so here's where you got to be
real careful Mark
um
my guess is and I could be out to lunch
your girlfriend slash shoot your fiancee
slash shoot your wife
made a blanket statement of some sort
that said come hell or high water I'm
going to take care of my mom P I need
you to know that about me I'm a kid
who's not going to let my mom be on the
street
and in your mind you're a planner and
you went to okay well what's the budget
for that gonna be and what's her 401
401K look like right and so what ends up
happening is you have a picture of take
care of Mom which is this is a problem
to solve and she has a picture of I'm
gonna take care of Mom which is a person
to love and what happens is y'all are
having a fight that shouldn't have to
happen because you're having two
separate conversations so I enter that
conversation and say I love the fact
that I love a woman
who wants to take care of her mom
yeah in my head here's what this looks
like I start thinking about how much is
this going to cost are we going to have
space we have to buy a different house
we're gonna have to move communities or
we get all those different nuts and
bolts and now you're in a very different
conversation which isn't are we going to
love Mom it is how are we going to do
this and you can say I am all about
loving you all about honoring your mom
I'm not in the business of loaning
people money yep they can live in a room
in my house we can get a mother-in-law
Suite on top of the garage here is a
core principle of mine and if she comes
back and says we're going to loan our
money to our family
now you've got a values issue right
that's less of a mathematical formula
issue or a risk issue that is a no I
loan money I don't loan money and now
you're talking about future issues in
your marriage which is why you date
right is this making sense
yeah because I kind of one what kind of
I know why she reacted this way because
out of the moment of emotion she said I
know that you're big on not loaning
money
um so she is aware of my general values
and boundaries
um but then like you were saying with
make the loving and complaining and
how do you do it together with someone
that you'd be one with in a marriage and
her family be my family
um
just kind of complicates here's uh
here's I'm gonna do um this is like a
pre-engagement gift we're gonna send you
one year of FPU I want you to watch all
the lesson videos with your girlfriend
and if her mom will join you that'd be
great too I want you to watch them
together and it will give her some
context of where you're coming from and
if nothing else it will give you all a
common language for which to build your
relationship or to make the hard
decision to
call it all right thanks for the call
Mark this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Kent
Coleman I am joined in studio the shower
by my colleague Dr John deloney and we
are taking your calls Triple eight eight
two five five two two five that is the
toll-free number eight eight two five
five two two five Talking Money talking
mental emotional health relationships
we're talking your work as it relates to
hey I want to get out of it or I want to
get into something better make more
money hey I'm stressed out I'm burned
out at home relationships are on fire
John and I are combining on all of those
topics plus of course your money
questions let's go to Clayton who joins
us now in San Antonio Texas Clayton how
can we help
hey guys uh thanks for having me on uh
I'm new to Dave Ramsey's program to the
content and
I guess on on baby step one right now
just trying to figure out what the best
way is to go about handling trying to
get out of the debt versus getting a
thousand dollars into emergency fund
well
first of all thanks for listening and
being new to the show and because you're
new we want to make sure you understand
those baby steps are in order so you are
in fact on baby step one and that's all
you should be focusing on not debt right
now so we're looking at Super intense
man we want to get a thousand dollars in
your savings account not a thousand two
hundred dollars not a thousand seven
hundred dollars a thousand dollars once
we get that now we are going to shift to
baby step two where we take your debts
and we're looking at your smallest debt
so let's say I'm making this up you got
a thousand dollars on a credit card and
then you got five thousand dollars on a
car and twenty thousand student loans
whatever it is we're gonna focus on that
smallest debt and knock that baby out
and then once we pay that off we take
the payment we're making on that and we
double it we dump that into if you will
the payment on the next debt so let's go
back
how much money do you have in savings
okay what brought you to this moment
ma'am
um just some really bad financial
decisions I've made in in the past and
I'm kind of right now at a rock bottom
and want to get my finances under
control uh when I have live film when it
comes to my finances and uh trying to
um better myself so I can ultimately
give back and help others good for you
dude how much debt do you have
uh total of about twenty thousand what's
that made up of
the car payments
um I owe I think 12 000 on that and then
uh College loan
um I don't I think about 8 000 still on
that
it takes me to 20 and then uh last year
I made some really poor decisions uh and
took out a few uh same day loans and uh
really regretting that now okay can I
ask you a bigger question
yes sir are you struggling with
addiction or do you just blow up a big
relationship
no what's underneath the twenty thousand
my I've
my rock bottom was six figures when a in
stupid financial decisions what's
beneath the twenty thousand dollars
just a bunch of stupid financial
decisions I mean I've I've never been
wise with the money uh that God has
given me and I've just squandered it and
spent it on foolish things and now it's
really come back to to bite me and haunt
me what's the car worth
uh the car is uh I got it for 13
000 uh making about 300 payments on it a
month right now so what's it worth if
you were to sell it today uh so it's
worth about eight thousand
um I have about
a four thousand dollar negative equity
on it sure all right and did you uh get
a degree with that student loan or is
that just partial time at school
that's just partial time all right so
let's go back let's go back to the the
to how do we get a thousand dollars
first right so you've got nothing right
now are you gainfully employed are you
working full-time part-time what's your
situation
I am on full time okay what do you make
uh uh I about 30 000 annually right now
okay
um it's not gonna be hard are you single
married what's your relationship status
is just a single okay what's your rent
or do you have a mortgage
about I ran about uh live my parents ran
about 100 a month okay dude all right so
here's the deal your first question was
hey do I focus on the thousand dollars
or paying off debt and I got great news
for you
um you can pay this debt off very very
quickly if you go all in are you willing
to go all in and stop making what you're
saying foolish decisions and just make
decisions for your future you willing to
do it yes or no
yes sir all right so a thousand dollars
that's selling stuff you got anything
you could sell you got a guitar some
shoes you don't wear what do you got
I do I do actually have a number of
stuff I can tell all right so that's one
way this so yeah he's right John's right
online yard sales Facebook Marketplace
done I mean dude sell anything that you
can sell all right let's say that we
could sell up to five hundred dollars
I'm just picking that number now we're
halfway there you're also single
and we are in a really great job economy
right now
Clayton San Antonio Texas how many
different places could you make twenty
dollars an hour even part-time
the answer is a lot what do you do to
make 30 grand
um I worked at a uh car dealership
well then we could just upgrade the gig
all together yeah right there's two ways
to go about this you either add the
part-time work or you just get a better
job
and and we bring in more income and
getting a thousand dollars is an
emergency fund you should be able to do
that in the next I'm going to say two
weeks if you really get after max if
you're selling something and you're
working on the weekend
come on man
I mean Walmart to hire you for for 1920
21 22 bucks an hour right now if you got
to stock shelves for a week at night and
not sleep you can do that you don't need
sleep to sell a car
for a short term okay we're just talking
about I want you to just see how
attainable how reachable a thousand
dollars is do you see it now
I do all right so that's baby step one
now let's talk about the the debt John I
mean we got a couple ways we could go in
the car he could keep that intensity up
and pay that car off pretty quick that's
what I would do I'd keep the car and
then the student loan of eight grand I
mean that's actually next on the list on
the snowball it's the eight grand unless
these payday loans you said you owed 20
but then you mentioned payday loans have
you paid those off
no sir well then what's the payday loan
how much
uh two three thousand okay so we so we
get a thousand dollars in the bank boom
we're gonna do that in ten days all
right and then we immediately go after
the payday loans we knock those out next
then we take on the student loan of 8
000 and then we take on the car
and if you work like a madman and you
double your income
one way or the other
you can do this very quickly
and here's the thing here here's what's
uh working for you is uh hang on the
line we're gonna send you a plan okay
we're going to walk you through it's I'm
going to send you all FPU the Financial
Peace University the flagship product
you can walk through all stuff and I'll
send you the every dollar app okay
only if you promise you're going to do
it
and so that's the benefit here's the
negative thing Ken and I have been doing
the show for long enough now that I'm
simply out of excuses in my personal
life because I've seen too many people
teachers who just say fine I'm gonna get
done teaching and I'm gonna go drive
Uber and after I get done driving Uber
I'm going to edit papers for grad
students and I'm gonna get up in the
morning I'm gonna do Postmates before I
go teach my classes and suddenly they're
out of a hundred grand in a calendar
year because they just got maniacal you
sound like somebody who overthinks and
overthinks and overthinks and over plans
and then you find yourself and you've
actually done nothing for all of your
effort is that fair
yes sir we've got to be done with that I
want you to stop thinking and I want you
to start acting
go get jobs go get jobs go get jobs and
it may be that your mom and dad say well
you need to rest honey I know you've
been working hard and you say not now
not in this season and you're going to
be stunned my brother if you stop the
thinking and start the doing in this
particular situation and by the way
everybody listening sometimes I tell
people stop acting you got to sit down
and grieve this you got to think through
this for a minute this isn't the season
for you brother this is the season to go
work work work work and you're going to
find yourself up up I mean right side up
with this financial situation in no time
yeah and Clayton you know what uh if
Dave Ramsey were here he would say I've
done a lot of dumb things with money so
cut yourself some sleep yeah dude this
is not insurmountable this
but we're not talking to some fool
you're fine you're a normal guy yeah
normal and you didn't dig too big of a
hole you got this get your chin up
shoulders back hey I want to thank Dr
John deloney for hanging out I want to
thank the crew behind the glass for
keeping us on the air and you America we
appreciate you this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's John deloney co-host of the Ramsay
show did you know over 18 million people
listen to The Ram fancy show every week
a lot of those people listen on one of
our 600 plus radio stations across the
country to find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey Show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about life
specifically money in your life and
relationships in your life and mental
health and your work and so much more
because well if you look at all of those
areas they're all intertwined every day
we want to give you a clear path to Hope
and transformation triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the phone
number I'm Ken Coleman Dr John deloney
joins me this hour we are here for you
it's a free call AAA
825-5225 let's go to Houston Texas where
we start with Diane this hour Diane how
can we help
yes thank you for taking my call you bet
I am in my Earth early 70s and making
out my will due to a terminal illness
and I am considering leaving uh my
approximately 350 000 worth of assets to
my grandchildren and none to my only
daughter who has chosen to be estranged
for me and won't let me see my
grandchildren uh my only grandchildren
and uh
I'm angry at her but
nevertheless I still have
um love for her and wished it could be
different but I don't see any
open the situation to tell you the truth
uh anyway I don't want to be a bitter I
am a Christian I don't want to be a
bitter angry person but at the same time
I just
and neither will God get from there
there's Diane there's a difference
between bitter and just heartbroken and
heartbroken's okay I am heartbroken
heartbroken's okay besides okay
um first what what is your terminal
diagnostic
um metastatic breast cancer I'm so sorry
oh my goodness what's that what's the
time limit they've given you
oh
no longer defined in that way because
there's so much that they're trying to
do so I'm doing pretty good right now
and
um that part I had faced and I'm
um thankful for every day God gave me
and uh
I'm trying to use it to the best
beautiful and I have a bunch of
grandchildren that uh
love me very dearly and I love them very
dearly and
um is your daughter aware of your your
medical situation
um I'm not sure she's aware of the
second round she was aware of the first
but I'm not sure she knows I have not
indicated to her
what happened to divide that
relationship up why does she choose to
not have you in her life
huh
she
she's always blamed me for all her
problems and she became very very
abusive sending me filthy messages over
the phone like on Mother's Day and stuff
and well give me an example give me an
example
oh like calling me horrible names that
start with c and blaming me for uh
just things that mistakes she made and I
think she's mentally ill but that's my
opinion that's not a diagnosis
so and uh I finally had to realize I
can't be in a relationship where I'm
constantly abused good for you so good
for you I backed off and
um she blocked my grandchildren's phone
me from my grandchildren's phone that I
bought for them
and so I blocked her from leaving me
these filthy messages absolutely good
for you and so here's the both and you
did the right thing
and it still hurts so bad
yes and if you your money
will encourage or facilitate
additional Behavior that's going to put
someone you love at risk which is your
daughter but someone you love at risk
which is your grandkids I would tell you
it's unethical to give them that kind of
jet fuel
you can create a trust that's got very
specific things in it that say if this
can only be used for educational
expenses for these kids after they say
you can do things like that but I even
recommend people limit the amount of
control they try to have from
the other side right at some site you
got to make peace with it here's the one
thing I'm concerned you're that you're
that's Weighing on you tell me if I'm
wrong
that at some
that you can somehow buy back her love
or buy back a relationship with those
grandkids after you're gone
no no I don't have
it okay I'm
no I don't think this is something that
can be fixed in this life okay I hate to
hear that and I also have I get it
um I I think that you have no
obligations
um you've got no this is what you're
supposed to do with that money it's your
money it's your inheritance that you're
leaving to be a blessing to whomever you
choose
and you are free to both be at peace
with who you decide and have your heart
broken that you wish it had been some
another way both of those things can be
true at the same time
I'm so so sorry yeah because I'm telling
you right now you deserve to have that
daughter sitting by you taking care of
you
well Diane we uh I'm heartbroken for you
we hurt for you and it's
it's our Earnest hope that uh
that she uh you and she can restore the
relationship
before your time here is done but you
should have no guilt as John said and
you do what's best for those grandbabies
and what you believe you should do with
that money do you have a good attorney
that's going to help you get all that
set up so that you feel like you're in
control and uh
but I I
try to follow the uh Ramsey Legacy
good where I do a controlled uh
so what do you call it trust control
trust so that they can't get into
trouble with money not leave them good
for you
do you have some people in your life
that are walking alongside you
yes good I've been blessed in that way
good lean on them call them on those
days that you just wake up and you're
just a a big weight in your chest yeah
that
um because you miss your baby girl
okay
set that up so you can call them and
just say I miss my baby girl today
Diane I want you to hear this from John
and I too you are not a failure nope
the choices your daughter made or the
choices that she made
you're a good woman you've lived a good
life and you're going to leave a legacy
you hear us
all right you bet thank you so much for
calling us
you got to finish this break you got to
finish this I was struggling I'll say to
people listening to this
um
I've just sat with too many people that
have had their eyes are wide open
because the person that they love the
person they were really pissed off at
the person they're really upset with is
gone it's a mist
few things are worth not healing a
relationship
make the phone call take the phone call
say you're sorry say I forgive you let's
be about healing moving forward
this is what that pain sounds like on
the other side of a relationship that
may never be healed and it's hard to
hear
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
thrilled that you're with us America I'm
Kidd Coleman joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney and we are taking your
calls the shower triple eight eight two
five five two two five it's always a
pleasure when uh we get the opportunity
for great men and women to stop by
interesting men and women people who are
moving the needle in their own unique
way and our guest joining us right now
is a very very accomplished individual a
New York Times best-selling author a
entrepreneurs entrepreneur we're talking
about Big Time success degrees from
Harvard Yale I mean I could go on and on
and on uh his latest book is entitled
nation of victims identity Politics the
death of Merit and the path back to
Excellence Vivek ramaswamy joins us now
on the Ramsey Show Vivek welcome
good to be on how are you uh we're
having a blast Dr John deloney is with
me as well and when I reviewed the book
I must tell you the thing that jumped
out to me and I couldn't be more excited
that someone's taking this issue head on
is I'm a huge fan of meritocracy I think
it's what makes uh America great I think
it makes any country great when we can
just let the human Spirit Go Achieve on
something that they've dreamed and they
just go earn it I think it's what makes
us special as human beings uh why this
book why now
so look I I agree with you America isn't
just what makes it Meredith just what
makes America great it is what makes
America itself it is part of the reason
that this is deeply personal to me it is
why my parents came legally as
immigrants to this country decades ago
was to come to a place where they could
pursue Excellence achieve whatever they
wanted their kids could achieve whatever
they wanted regardless of the color of
their skin regardless of the accent they
spoke with with their own hard work and
commitment and dedication so does it
deeply personally held value for me as
well and yet the reason I wrote the book
now is that there is a full frontal
assault on the idea of meritocracy
itself in our country the idea that
meritocracy is a myth founded on
systemic racism founded on Injustice and
I think that you know look there's a lot
there's a lot of reasons why that
philosophy has become popular has taken
a hold of multiple institutions in
recent years from hiring practices in
Corporate America to admissions policies
and in the very colleges that I attended
but at the end of the day I think
there's an opportunity today to revive A
New Path forward a path back to
Excellence a path back to
unapologetically pursuing Excellence I
think that's the heart of what it means
to be American and I think we live in a
moment where we're hungry for a cause
hungry for identity hungry for a higher
shared National perpetocracy as part of
the heart of what it means to be
American so you know that's why I wrote
the book when I did sure it was a sequel
to my first book woke Inc which was
about how Corporate America in
particular had pushed these victimhood
narratives of these anti-merocratic
practices but this book is less about
Corporate America and more about our
culture more broadly so it was a sort of
sequel to that last sure and one of the
things I appreciate that you've done in
this book is obviously the title is
nations of victims but you've got a
whole chapter entitled conservative
victimhood and I think what you're doing
here as an equal opportunity offender if
I might uh you're calling out that this
victimhood has has seeped in to both
sides of the political aisle or
ideological aisle it's not just on one
side I want you to unpack that for us
there's 11 chapters in the book and I
could not write a book about victimhood
in America without devoting at least one
of those chapters to My Tribe or or my
end of the political Spectrum the
conservative wing and I'm disappointed
in some ways because one of the things
that bothered me about the left-wing
victimhood narrative was that it
complained about adversity rather than
recognizing that hardship is not the
same thing as victimhood that's the
piece of this book hardship is not the
same thing as victimhood and I saw an
opportunity for the conservative
movement for the Republican party to
respond to those left-wing victimhood
narratives by becoming the political
movement that put greatness the
Unapologetic pursuit of greatness first
again of Excellence again and instead I
worry that the left may actually be
winning the culture War not with a bang
but with a whimper by infecting the
other side and causing them to play the
same game and what we have right now is
a new emergence of a conservative
victimhood culture that says that you
know what you have a grievance well
guess what we've been screwed over even
more and our grievance is even greater
and we're going to play the oppression
Olympics to compete on who's oppressed
more than
the other person and at the end of the
day there is no gold medalist in the
oppression Olympics it is just America
as a nation that loses in the end and I
think that there are two ways to end a
culture War one is one side defeats the
other the other way is it's more
frightening but I think the more
realistic outcome where both sides
actually get infected with the same
cancer while they battle each other
without realizing that they're actually
practicing the same the same sad path in
their own respective ways and so you
know it was one it was two chapters
people told me not to include in this
book one was a chapter on black
victimhood which I thought I had to be
explicit about if we care about black
lives if we care about restoring
meritocracy we're gonna have to talk
openly about a victimhood culture that I
think is a setback a source of major
setback for the African-American
community in the United States and they
said you can't write that chapter
because you're not black I don't believe
in that I think if we have to be able to
talk about these issues honestly we
ought to be able to talk about them no
matter what our race is but you know
what I also worry about the rise of a
new white victim but culture in response
that goes into playing that victimhood
Olympics and that oppression Olympics
and I think at the end of the day the
case I make in this book is that we have
to move from a national identity Center
on victimhood back to a national
identity centered on the pursuit of
excellence and the path from one to the
other actually runs through an
uncomfortable place that we call
forgiveness and and Christianity can be
a path to get there for those who are
not persuaded by the Christian Narrative
of forgiveness there are secular ones I
offer in the book as well from Emmanuel
Kant to others but that's what we're
going to have to rise to the occasion to
to realize not only as conservatives
necessarily but as Americans and I think
that that's the moment that that's the
need that the current moment calls for
so Vivek this is uh John deloney here
and my background is mental health and
relationships and counseling and
um this sounds eerily familiar to
sitting down with a couple
and the number of times I've told one
member of a couple if you win and she
loses y'all have both lost
or if you take this with this
relationship and you think you're going
to
settle things by defeating one another
what you're doing is you're setting your
marriage on fire and you're going to
find yourself having to build something
out of Ash instead of stopping so I'm
glad that you brought up forgiveness
that's I think it's just a Cornerstone
to mental health it's a Cornerstone to
humanity it's a Cornerstone any society
is somebody going first and saying all
right I'm not gonna I'm not gonna fight
you I'm not gonna fight you what does
that look like because I don't know that
we have a cultural narrative for
anything other than oh yeah hold my beer
I can yell louder how do you encourage
or what paint us a picture of what
forgiveness at that level even looks
like is that is that Pelosi and
McConnell getting in a room and being
like I'm sorry I'm sorry and then just
getting chips and queso for everybody
like what's that actually look like
I don't think it falls out of our
political class and you know what I love
the analogy you grew to marriage one of
the things I do in this book is I take
Concepts that are familiar in human
relationships but to extrapolate that to
the a different kind of human
relationship that we don't think about
very often which is the relationship
that we're all in with one another as
co-equal Citizens in a common shared
Republic that is a relationship too even
the relationship between us as Citizens
and the nation we live in the
relationship between myself and the
nation the relationship between yourself
and the nation that's that's a
relationship too and I think that we've
we can take a lot of the lessons that we
might get from you know husband and wife
relationships parent-child relationships
I go through different analogies in the
book and see what lessons and what
insights that gives us about the
relationship between co-equal citizens
and even a relationship between the
citizen and the nation and one of the
one of the chapters of the book is
actually entitled a theory of Duty okay
it's a play on John rawls's famous work
from the 20th Century a theory of
justice that was a North star for much
of late 20th century liberalism
this chapter might be a North star for
the future of a conservative movement in
in America I don't know
four is the Revival of this idea of
civic duty that as Citizens We're each
oh obsessed at this point myself
included I forget this description
myself over the last years I'm a big
proponent of Liberty it's good stuff
Vivek we're running up against a break
I'm sorry to cut you off that's such
good stuff that's why you need to get
the book Nations excuse me nation of
victims by Vivek ramaswamy identity
Politics the death of Merit and the path
back to Excellence thanks for being with
us sir this is good work and this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
six five four three
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney as we take your calls this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five hey I want
you to find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more all you got to do
is use the promo code Ramsay to get the
best deal today's question comes from
Megan in New Jersey I'm currently in
baby step two working to pay off 120 000
I make fifty two thousand dollars gross
and just picked up two side hustles to
speed the process along I work for a fan
family member and at times it can be
hard working for a sibling when they are
your boss ooh John you're warming up for
this one I hope I struggle with leaving
because I know they need me but this is
not what I pictured myself doing with my
life career-wise how do I separate
personal and business and start the life
I want while trying to finish paying off
debt uh John you can give the layered
version I always go with this bumper
sticker when I get a question like this
I say it's your life yes here's what I
would say just because it hurts just
because it's painful doesn't mean it's
the right decision
and always always choose guilt over
resentment
tell your mom I can't come home for
Thanksgiving this year and you're going
to feel guilty about it but choose that
over
buying a plane ticket that you can't
afford taking time off work that you
can't afford being mad all the way to
the airport all the way to the delayed
flight all the way to your mom's house
and being angry because you're gonna
ruin everything that's on you
once your relationship goes to
resentment it's an ash it's very hard to
come back from that so choose guilt over
resentment here say I'm gonna go get
another job because I got to make more
money I gotta do Phil X Y and Z and
they're gonna say but we need you about
you're gonna feel guilty if they bail on
you that's a choice that they make not
you if they look at your boundary and
they go then fine we don't want anything
to do with you they're the one acting
like children not you and you can be
heartbroken and be sad and grieve the
crap out of it because that'll hurt and
you still did the right thing yeah I
love that I I say it a little bit
differently but I like how you said that
choose the guilt but he's saying
metaphorically I mean you've done
nothing wrong here and and as I like to
tell people look
um you're going to disappoint some
people by making decisions that are
right for you but the disappointment is
on them if you don't do what you want to
do because of them the resentments last
for a long time maybe your entire life
and that's on you that's right and
that's uh that's what you're saying
there and prescribing that I love that
thank you so much for the question all
right let's get back to the phones
Charlotte North Carolina is where Steve
joins us Steve how can we help
uh we have we have a paid off house we
don't have any debt and we have uh one
point
1.2 million dollars net worth I make 65
I'm retired I retired from UPS and
National Guard and I get a disability
and my and I bring home every month 6
500 a month and my wife brings home 4
000 a month and in November I turned 62
and I'll start getting my Social
Security which would be about another
twenty five hundred dollars and we want
a RV that's about a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars but all we have is
fifty thousand dollars in cash and we're
trying to decide is it since we really
ain't not going to need that uh Social
Security money because you know we're
living good why can't we just take that
Social Security uh money and just
put it all toward an RV every month and
get it paid off quickly
because we don't tell you to borrow
we're never going to tell you to borrow
and it's not a good decision to borrow
especially an RV which is going to
immediately lose value
the every second you press down on the
gas it's just continued to devalue and
you guys are you guys are net worth
millionaires you're doing great this is
just an issue of patience but when you
assume debt you assume risk I
I trust the long-term viability of
Social Security
not very much I'll say it that way
that's the nicest way I can so that was
very nice I was trying to be I was
trying to be nice I would not sign up
for a five year seven year term
uh with the idea that I'm just going to
use my side money to pay something off
it's here's what it sounds like can I be
honest with you
yeah be honest man sounds like you're a
millionaire and it really pisses you off
you can't just go buy whatever the heck
you want because we all thought when we
became millionaires we could just buy
whatever we wanted and you can't even
buy an RV is that fair
it's just annoying
yeah yeah it's kind of annoying doing
this you know the fact that I guess
I'm 62 I've been in two Wars and you
know and this is what she really wants
because there's nobody at the house and
me and her and on the weekends we like
we want to be able to go to the uh to
the bike rallies
so Steve Steve what's keeping you from
going to the bike rallies and all the
other things you want to do on the
weekend
now
when we do that we have if we do that we
got to stay in a hotel and hotels are
like 300 to anywhere from 250 to 300 a
night yeah I know but a hotel is
99
700 cheaper than an RV
bingo
well Steve I was trying to push you to
say well why don't you just rent a
really nice SUV you know they they rent
these SUVs now and you know you rent it
for the weekend and then you leave it
you got the cash
I mean you're talking about all this
social security cash well okay let's
assume as John says that it keeps coming
in well now you guys got your weekend
that's your weekend fun so you go down
to the local RV guy and you go Bob
I want a 20-footer this weekend and uh
he gets you an RV and you guys go and
you have a blast at the biker weekend
and then you come back hopefully you
make it back from those things those
things seem a little violent but hey
who's judging and uh you come back
but you see what I'm saying you come
back and and you don't have a
depreciating asset on your hands and you
don't have a payment you don't have a
thousand dollar gas uh gas tank to fill
up
here's the thing dude like just being
straight up with you I would love a big
giant RV right now for me and my family
I'd love to see you drive
oh man yeah well you can get a little
one for not a hundred thousand dollars
okay okay what are you thinking about a
hundred thousand dollars is the is the
big kids what are you thinking about
what the RV yeah
I was a a Class B RV it's a Class B it's
like the uh the Sprinter van
dude you're that's like taught you're
yeah you're getting some Fancy Pants
stuff man yeah you got nice taste don't
you Steve
well it's just remember was so
conservative I mean she wasn't kind of
women that don't even want a Coach bag
we just so conservative and you know
this is something she asked for you know
I know Steve wait a second you're great
you're awesome here's the deal I wish I
wish we could get your wife on the phone
because here's the deal you're cringing
over a 300 a night hotel room and yet
you're willing to go in debt for a
hundred thousand dollar RV where's the
conservative in that my friend there's
no conservative I'll tell you what's
going on Steve welcome to the club
you're dealing with what mama wants and
you want to give it to her so bad
because you're a good guy and you love
that lady man and she's put her time in
you've put your time in you just want
something nice and you deserve something
nice here's here's what we're doing
we're just we're Ken and I are a couple
guys who love you and we're grateful for
you and I don't want to see you four
years in to a hundred thousand dollar RV
that's now worth 68 000 bucks and needs
an engine it has an engine issue and
then they come make an announcement that
we're not raising the rates in fact
we're gonna have to cut 10 percent of
Social Security to make whatever debt
balloon payment I I was making stuff up
here I'd much rather see you guys decide
hey what hotel do we want to stay at at
this rally yeah I was going to introduce
three words together that are beautiful
I think it could really help you with
your wife Hotel and Spa you're just
getting memorized
for you Steve
that's funny I could see Steve rolling
at the spot right you'd work over Steve
listen you all need to go have a good
time and do what you want to do on the
weekends you guys have earned it with
your conservative diligence and
discipline and we applaud you but my
friend you know it doesn't make sense
don't borrow money don't borrow money go
spend the money on nice hotels or rent a
nice SC or whatever you call it RV there
you go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman joined by Dr John
deloney this shower our scripture of the
day comes from Joshua 1 verse 9 have I
not commanded you be strong and
courageous do not be afraid do not be
discouraged for the Lord your God will
be with you wherever you go our quote
today from William Wallace men don't
follow titles they follow courage
little Braveheart reference there I
always love those old quotes because I
wonder how did we grab those like how'd
they write that down always fun uh to go
deep deep in history there the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five uh but before we get
to that John you get something that uh
uh you uh got together with Rachel Cruz
George camel on this is quite the
collaboration yeah sometimes things
happen in life and they're totally
outside our control but we can control
our thoughts and actions and we get to
decide who we're gonna be and how we're
going to respond so here's the deal if
you choose to float by and just let life
happen but wonder why your life's a mess
it's time to start being intentional
because when you start doing and
thinking things on purpose that's when
you get positive results I know it can
be tough when you don't have the right
tools or motivation to get started
that's why I'm super jazzed to introduce
the new 2023 Ramsay goal planner that
teaches you how to be intentional and
make goals that will have a long-term
impact in every area of your life this
year we completely redesigned the Ramsey
gold planner based on your feedback so
new cover new slim down size and new
motivating monthly content from my
friends Rachel Cruz and George Campbell
to keep you moving all year long coming
together to help you work on your
financial relational and spiritual goals
all three areas of your life are
important the goal planner sold out last
year it will sell out again so get your
2023 planner today by the way I don't
know what to get her I don't know what
to get
ramseysolutions.com
planner this will sell out we only print
a limited amount of them because we
can't sell these in you know August of
next year because the year will be over
so we sell them out quick
get your 2023 planner today
ramseysolutions.com
planner good stuff all right let's get
back to the phones Jonathan joins us in
uh Los Angeles Jonathan how can we help
hello Jonathan
hey how's it going guys we're having a
blast how can we help
hi I have a question a little bit of
background um I have a couple random
properties and my primary residence and
um
about net worth of a million but you
know all together I got I'm in the hole
for maybe like 2.3
um so I'm wondering if I should sell my
prop rental properties and pay off my
primary evidence
um and you know just have like fifty
thousand dollars cash left over but with
everything paid for okay so walk us
through uh the the whole 2.3 million in
debt is that on the rental properties
and your primary residence or is there
more debt involved
uh no that's just uh on the property
that's correct okay so what are the two
rental properties worth
and then walk me through rental property
one what it's worth what you owed so I
can so we can break that down
okay I went to property one it's worth
about eight hundred thousand uh I owe
about 500 000 on that one and then
rental property two is worth about 750
and I owe about 300 on that one okay and
then on my residential my primary
residence
um we owe about 200 I mean 600 sorry and
it's worth about a million okay great
all right uh so moving both rental
properties uh would get you
so sounds like a good smart plan to me
because I mean you just you've got a lot
of debt man you've assumed a lot of risk
here
um but the good news is the good news is
is that you're not upside down in them
and you can get out of these properties
so what would keep you from doing this
you called us to ask you should you do
it what's keeping you from doing it
I'm competitively invested in real
estate I love real estate it's just you
know we were thinking of maybe
selling one of them and paying off the
one where we only owe 300 or they would
be worth maybe like 90 000 on that one
and then just paying that off quick but
it would still keep our primary
residence uh owed on that
um and then I'm thinking about switching
careers in the near future so that's
something you know kind of the safety
net I want to pay it off but it would
just kind of
I'd rather keep the rental but changing
careers is what's making me hold back on
or making me want to sell everything and
just pay off it what are you changing
what are you changing careers too
I'm thinking about going into a trucking
industry class a driver something like
that really yeah well John I can't see
any reason why I would I would
absolutely liquidate these uh I would
keep the primary residents pay that off
but this is going to take a lot of
stress off of you
um you're going to be able to pay that
that primary down uh you know pretty
substantially yes
yeah my only other concern in my life
too is you know it would take us because
like I said we really love real estate
it would take us quite a bit of time to
kind of save up that money and buy
something
that's okay you love the fantasy
you love having a bunch of nice things
with your name on the title but you
don't own those things dude the bank
does
I love love love real estate I love the
idea of it I love the appreciation of it
I love being able to price something a
little bit under Market to help out my
neighbors I love all of it
I'm not going to sign myself up in a
risk I'm not going to put that level of
risk in my financial portfolio I'm not
going to put my family at that risk
without doing it the right way so yes
when you look at you say wow I love this
I can't afford it
man there's a lot of stuff I love that I
can't afford right
um that's just where you find yourself
and I think it's making peace with math
and make peace with everybody says make
peace with peace
man yeah but let's I know what everybody
says but let's just let's talk about
this because I always I I love seeing
this stuff on social media and you got
these guys out there trying to Hawk
people into all this buying real estate
it's all about cash flow bro cash flow
that's what I want to talk about let's
talk about real cash flow okay on on
rental one you said you owe 500 it's
worth about 800 what are you making with
rent on that one
um I profit after I pay mortgage about
uh 1200 bucks okay that's what I wanted
is that including in your depreciation
cost are you having a fun decide for
when the air conditioner goes out and
the roof falls out and the financial
Foundation needs repair
or is that just uh yeah I have about 10
10K for each of those you know so I have
ninety thousand dollars in emergency
fund which is more than three to six
months okay my personal but I keep
something as well all right so let's run
the same exercise on rental property
number two after all expenses what are
you netting per month
um about the same thing it's
um lower on Market rent on that all
right so here's the deal
and I'm not knocking this I'm just
trying to give you perspective
2400 bucks you've got debt on those two
of eight hundred thousand dollars
combined if I wrote the numbers down
properly okay and you're making twenty
four hundred dollars a month but you're
leveraged eight hundred thousand dollars
for 2400 a month and let's go one step
further that's not that much money
what's your mortgage
uh my mortgage is about 3 000.
so what if I told you I could free up
600 in cash flow every month
by just paying your mortgage off
yeah do you see what I'm saying that was
the thought is if we say if we pay off
you know one of the lower rental that we
owe a load more on that that would take
care of our mortgage so essentially
you'd be around the same thing no no no
you're still talking about cash flow
here's what I'm talking about you make
twenty four hundred dollars a month
coming in and you send three thousand
dollars out every month towards your
mortgage
what if you sacrifice that 2400 bucks
coming in every month and did not send
out three thousand dollars every month
that's a six hundred dollar a month net
gain to you do you see what I'm doing
yeah if you sell those two rental
properties and pay off your primary
residence that's three thousand dollars
a month you're not sending out to
somebody to make somebody else rich
all right and no stress and there's no
stress and no risk and then you know
what job you can do after that whichever
one you want to because you have a
million dollar paid off house you're
free brother last thing you want to be
doing is driving on that truck and
having to worry about all the stuff
going on with those rental properties
because believe me you know you own
three homes
this is a no-brainer for the switch
they're all for Freedom solve for
Freedom don't solve for cash flow don't
solve for potential risk solve for
freedom I love that and imagine all the
risk that you will have avoided once you
sell these houses sell a man pay off
that primary home or be able to do that
three in 30 days my brother
congratulations amazing so fun all right
always fun to be with you John thank you
John deloney I want to thank the guys
behind the glass for keeping us on the
air and mostly America we want to thank
you for listening we do this show for
you it is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsey show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world to get
your daily dose of advice on life and
money check out all of our shows from
the Ramsay Network wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]